famous Danish philosopher søren
kierkegaard once rode to be that self
which one truly is is something to first
think about when you're trying to figure
out your own personal purpose so the
three questions I want you to think
about are as follows what are you about
what are the attributes the values the
likes the dislikes I'm gonna get it on a
piece of paper and say what am I about
what do I want to be about the second
one is Who am I Who am I trying to be
who are those people I aspire to who are
those things in myself that I want to
change and then the last question is how
how am I going to show up each and every
day in this life of mine once you begin
defining deciding and developing your
what your who and your how at the end of
the day that's going to create a pathway
to purpose purpose really is your
defined sense of self and it starts with
you purpose is not given to you purpose
is not bought purpose is defined and
decided and developed by you now
ostensibly we all have to work somewhere
and so what you're trying to do is to
match as best possible that defined
sense of self with an organization that
ideally has as close a match to that
defined sense of self so you're looking
for an organization that also has
defined itself how you want to view the
world how you live the world and when
there's a balance as close to as
possible as a hundred percent between
your defined sense of self and the
organization's defined sense of purpose
then in your role and reciprocally in
your life you will be living and working
with a sense of purpose
so once you've defined your sense of
personal purpose once ideally you're
working an organization has a higher
purpose hopefully you have a purpose
mindset we'll come back to that but when
things aren't in alignment when you're
not in a sweet spot you will actually
fall into one of two other mindsets a
job mindset or a career mindset so
here's how that looks a job mindset will
just feel like a paycheck
it's very transactional you just punch
it in you're punching out and the
reasons for falling into that job
mindset usually come because you're
disengaged you're disenfranchised you're
disillusioned with either yourself
and/or the organization that has power
mongers hierarchical bureaucracy they're
not listening to you fill in the blank
that's a job mindset very sad equally
sad however is the career mindset now
don't think of career in this case as
you know what people would call career
development think of this as what I call
girth so when people are in the career
mindset they're actually trying to
extend girth and girth comes in several
forms such as title people trying to
climb the ladder for a fancier title pay
people pushing people out of the way so
that they can get more pay more
remuneration budget people actually
hoarding ideas so that they can look
good in front of their boss so that they
get a higher budget for the next year
these types of trappings that are
systemically found in the organization
create lots of leaders who have that
career mindset so when you have a
portion of the organization in the job
mindset aided and abetted by those
leaders who are aspiring to the career
mindset then you have a lack of purpose
but if you have an alignment between
your personal purpose ie one of higher
purpose the organization's good deeds
and you feel good about this you're
being listened to feel good in your life
it's all working copasetic lee you're
now in the purpose mindset and you're
going above and beyond the call of duty
in your role you are a transparent
individual in that role you're almost
altruistic it doesn't feel like a job it
feels like it's your life so there's
this life work integration not work-life
balance when you're in the purpose
mindset and ultimately both you and the
organization are then in the sweet spot